[Musique]
ravi de vous retrouver sur l'antenne de
lcp public sénat pour ce nouveau numéro
d' europe hebdo qui est à l'heure des
élections européennes et on va parler
aujourd'hui d'écologie un thème majeur
de cette campagne que fait l'europe pour
l'écologie est un moteur ou un frein sur
cette question comme le glyphosate et
bien c'est le thème de cette émission et
on en débat avec quatre invités quatre
candidats à ces élections bonjour
michèle rivasi bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne sortante numéro deux sur la
liste europe écologie les verts vous
vous représentez en face de vous pascal
durand vous aussi au député sortant et
vous êtes sur la liste renaissance
ladewig en marche modem c'est bien ça
alors juste nous accueillons également
d'avenir l'empereur sur la liste debout
la france bonjour vous êtes porte parole
du parti vous présentait donc pour la
première fois mon en face de vous avons
patrick le hyaric
on ne vous présente plus député européen
sortant est en lice pour un troisième
mandat c'est bien ça au parlement
européen
et bien c'est parti pour le débat
[Musique]
la protection de l'environnement la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
c'est une priorité pour l'union
européenne l'union qui se targue d'être
en pointe dans ce domaine est d'avoir
contribué à la signature des accords de
paris sur le climat ont fait un petit
état des lieux avec laszlo gelabert
[Musique]
l'urgence climatique une priorité pour
l'union européenne en 2015
les 28 états membres moteur de la coop
21 signent l'accord de paris avec 169
autres pays
objectif limiter le réchauffement
climatique en dessous de deux degrés
avant 2100
chaque pays doit réduire jusqu'à 40 %
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
15 ans des promesses pourtant loin
d'être tenues si les émissions de co2
ont baissé en finlande et au danemark
elles ont augmenté dans une majorité
d'états européens les plus mauvais
élèves
malte et l'estonie la france elle se
situe en milieu de tableau
elle a émis 4 158 millions de tonnes de
co2 en 2016
466 en 2017 soit une hausse de 1,7 pour
cent soixante associations
environnementales ont même attaqué la
france en justice
nous avons été plus de 2 millions
assignés pour soutenir la sphère du siec
2 millions assignés pour attaquer l'état
français en justice pour son inaction
climatique
malgré tout le combat continue récemment
les eurodéputés ont voté l'obligation
pour les camions neufs de réduire leurs
émissions de co2 de 30% d'ici 2030 il y
a urgence
d'après l'agencé européenne de
l'environnement cinq cent mille
personnes meurent chaque année à cause
de la pollution de l'air en europe
[Musique]
vaste sujet vaste chantier
première question pour vous peut-être
michèle rivasi on a l'impression quand
même que tout est un peu partie de la
coque 21
la prise de conscience l'action les pays
européens se sont fixé des objectifs
assez contraignant aujourd'hui pour vous
est-ce que le bilan de l'europe sur
l'écologie est plutôt positif mais en ce
qui concerne le climat oui et moi même
j'étais rapporteur de la loi sur l'union
de l'énergie et l'objectif c'était une
concordance entre la coop va notamment
aux verts au parlement européen et les
objectifs fixés par l'europe et là on a
dit 2030 diminution de 40% de gaz à
effet de serre parce que c'est ça mon
problème et on veut aller jusqu'à même
les écologistes demandent 60%
et puis 32 % d'efficacité énergétique
voyez il ya beaucoup de chiffres il ya
beaucoup d'ambitions beaucoup de
chiffres oui est-ce que c'est pas un peu
trop
oui non mais c'est à l'échelle
européenne voyez pourquoi les
écologistes sont pour l'europe parce que
c'est à l'échelle européenne qu'on peut
résoudre une barnier du problème du
réchauffement climatique il faut se
fixer des objectifs et avoir une
gouvernance de l'union européenne pour
dire attention la france là vous
respectez pas vos objectifs puisque vous
avez augmenté au gaz à effet de serre
donc la commission a grâce aussi aux
citoyens et bien on va pouvoir réduire
ses gaz à effet de serre et c'est au
niveau de la gouvernance de l'europe
qu'on peut le faire
pascal durand delà des bonnes intentions
et ce qu'il y a eu vraiment des avancées
concrètes et notamment depuis cette coop
21 quand même l'europe pour rien en 2019
déjà première chose il faut pas limiter
la question environnementale simplement
au climat et à l'accord de paris je
partage tout ce qui a été dit évidemment
par michel mais il faudrait quand même
en amont dire que l'europe elle est le
lieu aux normes le plus au monde sur
tout ce qui est lié aux produits
chimiques à la santé et sur sur
l'environnement d'une manière générale
l'air qu'on respire l'eau qu'on boive et
c'était excellent peu des clés
l'élastique contre des menaces big fan
tous et je les gma c'est vraiment le
continent sur cette planète qui à
jaillir initié une vraiment les
politiques les plus avancés en matière
et pour les présentable donc ça c'est
positif et il faut le dire parce que
comme le dit michel on
on critique et on entend tellement de
critiques de l'europe où on dit
l'accueillir op très éloigné de la vie
des gens mais l'europe c'est la vie des
gens au quotidien c'est l'alimentation
l'air qu'on respire le look on boit tout
ça c'est l'europe
donc oui pour le climat il ya des
objectifs après il faut les mettre
on est tout à fait d'accord mais sur
votre question initiale est ce que
l'europe est l'élément jédir un élément
moteur sur la question environnementale
écologiques et climatiques la réponse
est clairement oui
est ce que vous partagez cette position
patrick le hyaric oui le il ya
différentes institutions européennes
donc le parlement européen sur une série
de questions représenté à légiférer
positivement comme cela vient d'être dit
le sur l'air sur l'eau sur la
l'agrochimie sur le l'enquète sur
volkswagen il ya concrètes pour vous
c'est pas des directs ou tafer le
glyphosate le pardon est très en avant
puisque il
il a débattu avec le conseil européen et
la même débattu avec le gouvernement
français pour abaisser la laddh la durée
le moment lequel on va son va sortir
alors daniel entre art je vous donne la
parole
est ce que vous trouvez que l'europe est
trop volontariste au contrat passé
ambitieuse alors déjà s'est jamais à
faire une distinction entre l'europe qui
est une
on parle de l'union européenne voilà et
l'union européenne en tant
qu'institution que nos critiques
beaucoup à debout la france puisqu'elle
est selon nous peu démocratique où elle
est orientée uniquement en faveur d'une
économie financiarisée mondialisé et pas
justement une coopération des nations
qui pourraient coopérer en vue de la
transition écologique qui pourrait
inspirer
il pourrait ouvrir sur des projets
d'avenir que ce soit la voiture
électrique la voiture propre pour plus
d'écologie en fait qui a été dit est
vrai c'est à dire qu en europe on a le
niveau de normes maximum je pensais
également à l'alimentation qui est on a
aussi on regarde l'ensemble de la
planète on n'a pas à rougir les
différents pays européens est d'ailleurs
souvent aussi c'étaient des initiatives
nationales on peut penser aux pays
scandinaves par exemple qui font qu en
europe nous sommes à un niveau
intéressant
mais dans le même temps et c'est ça et
je pense la différence de debout la
france avec tous les autres intervenants
c'est que l'union européenne est insérée
dans un système de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce dans un site à
bouilly bréchand c'est le traité le ceta
qui est un danger pour l'écologie nous
t'avons et dont il n'a même pas été
ratifiés si on est à l'assemblée
nationale et je conclus là dessus qui
est on à l'assemblée nationale qui n'a
même pas été ratifié par les parlements
nationaux et donc je pense qu'une forme
de schizophrénie a donné des objectifs
our nation mais en même temps rester
justement actions vis-à-vis de schiste
dans le concret moi je voulais me parler
du mix énergétique ça fait partie des
objectifs sur les photos ou est-ce qu'on
en est aujourd'hui au niveau européen
les énergies renouvelables ça représente
combien dans alors les énergétiques si
on nous laissait une compétence des
nations la preuve c'est que la france
est dans le nucléaire
alors mes pleins d'autres pays qui n'ont
pas mais l'objectif c'est notamment nous
orlando programme des écolos c'est 100%
d'énergies renouvelables en 2005 ça
c'est naples c'est faisable avait bien
sûr et en plus c'est bon pour tout et
pour tout le monde c'est bon pour les
gaz à effet de serre c'est bon pour
limiter l'importation des énergies
fossiles
c'est bon pour
si vous voulez l'europe s'est fixée 20 %
comme comme chypre dont alors seulement
32 % en 2003 en 2030 mais bon et pour
atteindre le plus possible en 2050 bon
mais l'important c'est que et c'est pour
ça que je suis pas d'accord ou par du
climat là l'europe elle est volontariste
nous on voudrait qu'elle aille plus loin
parce qu'il ya un vrai enjeu regardez
tous ces jeunes qui manifestent dans la
rue il dit ça va pas assez vite c'est
l'écologie sans transition maintenant on
écoute les greta tolbert et ses termes
et et à la raison là dessus de l'europe
n'est pas seule ya les états unis la
chine et l'europe
elle est leader et il faut qu'elles
montrent que les autres vont suivre et
c'est pour ça que si nous on est très
exigeants
on va limiter nos gaz à effet de serre
et les autres regardez trump
il est anti les climato sceptiques tout
ce que vous voulez mais la californie
elle suit ce que fait l'europe bien
d'autres états aux états unis qui
suivent et la chine
on la pousse justement pour que l
développe énormément les énergies
renouvelables à l'heure actuelle il ya
plus de 230 milliards d'euros investis
pour les énergies renouvelables
vous savez ce qu'il ya pour le nucléaire
14 milliards d'euros donc vous voyez
bien que l'avenir c'est des énergies
renouvelables alors je voudrais vous
poser une autre question parce qu'il
faut avancer dans ce débat il ya une
idée qui revient un peu chez chez chez
tous dans tous les programmes c'est
l'idée d'une taxe aux frontières des
produits extra communautaire ça veut
dire que l'on taxe est une sorte de
droit de douane sur des produits
fortement pollueurs est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cette idée ce qui
évidemment mais ça répond en fait
indirectement à la question vous venez
de poser
michel cercle le fait de dire il ya
l'europe et puis il ya le reste du monde
déjà sur le reste du monde fomente et
l'honnêteté de dire qu'une grande partie
des pollutions du reste du monde
notamment en chine ou ailleurs
ils viennent de nos propres industriels
qui ont externalisé comme on dit leur
production mais bon les qui ont plus on
vous fait perdre des emplois chez nous
en europe etc mais concrètement vous
avez raison c'est à dire que si on
considère vous avez commencé l'émission
en expliquant qu'il y avait cinq cent
mille morts prématurées c'est pas des
morts qui sont directement ce sont des
morts prématurées qui sont directement
liés à d'autres
clairement il faut agir si on considère
qu'il faut agir comme l'europe n'est pas
un îlot isolé à l'intérieur de la
planète
il faut qu'on met effectivement aux
frontières et que l'on fasse respecter
exactement la manière dont vous l'avez
évoqué sur les grands contrats
internationaux
les traités qu'ils soient avec le canada
ou avec les autres
il faut qu'on fasse respecter les normes
environnementales et sociales mais là on
me parle des recettes environ notamment
en mettant 7e par les taxes et par le
fait qu'on impose dans le cadre des
relations que nous avons les uns avec
les autres
aucun produit ne peut rentrer et ne doit
entrer en europe s'il ne respecte pas
nos propres normes environnement trick
le hyaric vous accepter l'idée de cette
taxe elle fait partie de ce que dit le
parti communiste
oui il faut il faut des droits de
douanes dès lors que l'an le saut libre
échangisme à intégral comme il l'appelle
désormais et détruit les protections
sociales partout et détruit aussi la
biodiversité fait mal
allo fait mal allaire et coûte
extrêmement cher donc il faut
complètement modifié cela rendez vous
compte qu'aujourd'hui on est en train
d'agrandir le port du arrêt de dunkerque
pour accueillir de nouveaux containers
ces nouveaux conteneurs vont et demi sur
des camions au lieu d' ennemis sur le
sueur sur le train et donc on est
d'ambon glacial on est dans une logique
totalement folle donc il ne suffit pas
de faire des discours sur
l'environnement
il faut changer complètement les
logiques qui sont à l'oeuvre aujourd'hui
dont cette affaire des traités de libre
échange à vos si vous réclamez une taxe
aux frontières sur les produits extra
communautaires qui qui viendraient en
europe
oui expliqué nous réjouit que la
république en marche le 10 mai ce que
vous oubliez de dire c'est que c'est
totalement aujourd'hui interdits
illégale par les traités européens qui
interdisent typiquement donc de mettre
une taxe aux frontières de l'union
européenne puisque c'est pas conforme le
police méchant et autres et nous ont
posé sur la géorgie vous voulez le
chercheur d'acier schmoll
tout le monde est heureux parce que je
suis fier mais que que des contraintes
telles que les traités notamment le
traité de lisbonne interdit de mettre en
oeuvre ce genre de protection dans le
cadre de l'organisation mondiale du
commerce
et encore plus lorsque l'union
européenne est partie à des contrats
internationaux comme par exemple c'est à
là on est en train d'ouvrir le taffetas
le mercosur avec le ceta ou vous donner
la possibilité y compris à des molécules
interdites je pense à la le trajet par
exemple qui va peut-être entrer depuis
le canada il ya aussi un risque sur les
ogm et nous qui en principe ne sont pas
censés venir du canada mais comme il
n'ya pas de moyen de contrôler ce qui
arrive et qu'on est dans une société
complètement ouverte vous augmenter le
risque finalement de faire venir des
produits qui ne répondent pas aux normes
et on en parlera peut-être sur le
glyphosate danse est un petit peu la
même chose de moi je veux bien commettre
cette taxe nous aurons le réclamaient
d'ailleurs il faudrait aussi réfléchir à
des protections au niveau national la
réalité c'est que ce n'est pas possible
dans le cadre des traités actuels et
nous on est pour une protection si vous
voulez aux frontières européennes
c'est une protection sociaux environ 10
pour être cohérent avec ce que fait leur
viennent en france on tient pas compte
du coût du co2 et on tient pas compte
des différences sociales parce que il ya
des acquis sociaux qu'on a en europe qui
n'existe pas dans ces pays et c'est pas
pénaliser d'où l'importance de protéger
le marché européen doux et ça c'est pas
aujourd'hui attendez c'est pas que quand
vous dites ça va à l'encontre et
regardez il y avait les panneaux
photovoltaïques jeunes à voir là dedans
et on a dit c'est du deux villes sociale
il faut se réveiller
euros il ya bien quelqu'un affaires
européennes a taxé les panneaux
photovoltaïques chinois pour dire il
faut plutôt faire en sorte à ce que ses
pattes panneaux photovoltaïques se
fabrique en europe
donc ne vous dites pas que c'est alors
que le traité n'a pas aidé car quand tu
vois une volonté politique est ce que la
volonté politique existait ce qu'on peut
faire c'est ça c'est une vraie question
on avisera prendre un autre exemple
évidemment michel a raison et on peut le
meur la question c'est est ce qu'on va
le faire
ou est ce qu on a la capacité de
l'imposer politique je vous donner un
autre exemple par exemple la sidérurgie
on sait que la chine subventionne très
sa production d'acier
on le sait et on voulait mettre des
taxes et on pouvait parfaitement ces
mêmes bandes est proposé à 200 %
ça a été bloqué parce qu'il y avait
unanimité écouter alors je vous en prie
il se trouve que vous avez trois députés
européens ici levé par dont vous avez le
droit par de justice des communautés
européennes mais interdit de
subventionner on l'a vu encore play sur
le redressement google parlait pas ne
vous ne connaissez pas encore à gagner
du temps laissez moi vous êtes dans le
mépris ni chez les intervenants du
représentant du plaignant c'était très
bien dormi avec madame aux finitions je
continue donc par exemple sur la figure
giroud voulait imposer une taxe à 200%
on a été bloquée notamment par le
royaume uni donc la question qu'on va se
poser et qu'on doit se poser c'est un il
faut qu'on arrive à mettre une taxe
carbone aux frontières européennes
mais pas que on à la question du
transport oui c'est très bien ça vient
d'être évoquée avec la question des
containers au monde
tant que nous continuerons à
subventionner et c'est un des enjeux de
la prochaine mandature et notamment des
financements bancaires
tant qu'on continuera à financer les
exonérations sur les kérosène qu'on
continuera à financer et à subventionner
le transport international
alors nous avons un problème alors
surtout avec la nouvelle route de la
soie et les camions que les chinois
veulent faire circuler on va avancer
dans ce débat il y à un domaine sur le
cas sur lequel l'europe fred beaucoup
c'est celui du glyphosate un dossier qui
divise cette substance active de
pesticides qui est susceptible d qui est
suspecté pardon d'être cancérigènes
la commission européenne a renouvelé son
autorisation il ya peu mais la france
continuera de s'y opposer explications
de laszlo gelabert on en parle après
[Musique]
c'est un sujet sensible qui divise les
européens
le glyphosate un herbicide classé
cancérogène probable par l'organisation
mondiale de la santé utilisés par le
géant industriel monsanto en novembre
la commission européenne se réunit pour
prendre une décision faut-il renouveler
le glyphosate pour 15 ans ou carrément
l'interdire comme le préconise la france
ou l'italie
la commission opte finalement pour un
renouvellement sur cinq ans décision
votée par 18 pays membres dont
l'allemagne et les états membres
hier ont voté en faveur de la
proposition de la commission pour la
prolongation à l'autorisation du
glyphosate pour une durée de cinq ans
nous sommes satisfaits de ce résultat
un prolongement qui suscite la colère
des associations pour l'environnement la
france marque son opposition
elle réduit le délai d'interdiction sur
son sol j'ai demandé au gouvernement de
prendre les dispositions nécessaires
pour que l'utilisation du glyphosate
soit interdite en france dès que des
alternatives auront été trouvés et au
plus tard dans trois ans mais depuis
emmanuel macron est revenu sur son
annonce lors d'un débat citoyen dans la
drôme
il a reconnu qu'une sortie du glyphosate
aussi rapide serait compliqué en
attendant les pays européens prennent
des mesures en ordre dispersé la france
a interdit l'usagé du glyphosate pour
les particuliers l'italie en a interdit
l'utilisation dans les espaces publics
dans trois ans et demi l'union
européenne devra choisir entre le
renouvellement ou une sortie définitive
pour cet herbicide
[Musique]
alors patrick le hyaric une question
pour vous est-ce que le glyphosate a
selon vous une longue vie devant lui en
europe où pensez-vous que l'union dan
finira un jour par l'interdire on sent
qu'il ya beaucoup division il ya il y à
des délibérations du parlement européen
qui vise comme ça vient d'être dit
encore récemment l'arrêté assez
rapidement au terme de trois ans mais
c'est la position et non pas le et n'ont
pas donné la possibilité de le
renouveler
donc il faut faire en même temps ces
deux choses c'est à dire il faut
respecter ce délai et créer des
conditions pour que les agriculteurs il
est des solutions de rechange c'est à
dire il faut à la fois aider la
recherche tous azimuts la recherche
biologique la recherche y compris sur
des produits alternatifs
il ya d'ailleurs des expériences qui se
font de si de là je connais une petite
usine à loudéac trois ans c'est très
court est ce que concrètement petit
médina loudéac qui travaille déjà sur un
produit alternatif je l'avais d'ailleurs
dit tu es là pascal au ministre de
l'environnement de l'époque ton ami
nicolas hulot qui la connaissaient
également et donc il faut rechercher
vers la haye ce qu'on est prêt à trouver
un remplaçant glyphosate aujourd'hui
même le cnrs a publié comme quoi ils ont
trouvé une molécule aujourd'hui même
mardi 30 avril à 2019 pour justement
remplacé le glyphosate
donc il y a les moyens techniques mais
je voudrais revenir un petit peu en
arrière parlement européen a demandé
l'interdiction sur cinq ans
l'interdiction le parlement en automne
et il ya les états et les étangs demandé
le renouvellement pour cinq ans la
france elle a bien voulu faire le gros
dur en disant on va interdire sur trois
ans sauf qu'ils n'ont pas mis dans la
loi alimentation et agriculture
ce qui fait que quand on voit les
chiffres et exemples fait qu'augmenter
encore mais si vous voulez l'utilisation
dudit faisable donc ça aussi c'est une
volonté politique on a les alternatives
à l'heure actuelle il faut aller à
l'encontre de ce lobby chimiques qui dit
on peut pas s'en passer alors vous voyez
il ya maintenant des alternatives et
surtout sur le danger
regardez ce qui se passe aux etats unis
13 mille agriculteurs ont porté plainte
ils ont des leucémies des cancers etc et
la justice a montré avec des éléments
scientifiques que c'est cancérigène ses
responsables de la mort des agriculteurs
donc il n'y a pas le choix
nous on veut une agriculture
respectueuse de la santé d'environ
amiens l'empereur votre position sur ce
dossier du glyphosate
oui ce serait bien si on pouvait
l'interdire plus rapidement mais il ya
comme une réalité et j'en reviens à ce
que je disais un pardon de vous déranger
tous mais dans le cadre actuel des
traités et notamment des traités
internationaux mais pourquoi les livres
étaient là vous interdisez en france
s'engage il serait un peu non détruits
des traités internationaux
je répète qui permettent de faire venir
des produits qui sont produits y compris
avec du glyphosate puisque dans le cas
de paris l'entrée c'est à vous allez
faire venir des produits traités par le
glyphosate ça serait très compliqué pour
nos agriculteurs de se voir interdire
d'utiliser quelque chose que par
ailleurs on fait venir j'ajoute qu'il
faut trouver très vite la solution de
substitution
et là encore il ya un problème au niveau
des traités européens puisque il
faudrait plus de recherche plus
d'investissements un peu comme font nos
concurrents à la chine les etats unis y
compris de l'argent public ce qui est
aussi interdit aujourd'hui pour être
pour être pour être être un peu pénible
quand même pour être dans une optique un
peu moins critique je pense que la
solution intermédiaire qui se dégage en
france est pas mauvaise puisqu'elle est
à la fois sur une logique d'interdiction
et de substitution du glyphosate mais en
même temps elle est ce une période pour
nos agriculteurs pour trouver des
solutions de rechange
il ya un petit espoir c'est que à
l'intérieur même du capitalisme vous
avez vu que bayer se mord les doigts
d'avoir acheté monsanto pour semaine
marque est invendable désormais
exactement qui se passe quand même des
choses intéressantes va rester dans le
système capitaine
avant de faire réagir parce qu'alors je
voudrais vous faire écouter sur cette
question du glyphosate ce que propose un
autre candidat en lice pour ces
élections européennes il s'agit de
françois asselineau du parti union
populaire républicaine interrogé par
nathalie guille war et alex rougerie
écouter la france qui est quand même la
sixième puissance économique mondiale
n'a pas les moyens d'interdire le livre
mais on a appris il ya quelques jours
que le vietnam le petit vietnam dont le
pib très inférieur au nôtre a décidé
souverainement d'interdire le glyphosate
donc nous si on veut c'est un exemple on
pourra en prendre des quantités d'autres
si on veut sortir de l'union européenne
se libérer du carcan de l'union
européenne c'est papar'oc sinophobie
volonté de se refermer sur soi c'est
pour que les peuples et que le peuple
français reprenne sa décision si
d'autres peuples d'europe veulent
conserver leurs rivaux a très bien pour
eux mais nous on veut l'interdire et je
vous propose dans la foulée d'écouté
florian philippot qui mène la liste des
patriotes et qui nous a cité une mesure
phare pour l'environnement à mettre en
oeuvre en priorité notamment sur cette
question des pesticides et goûter nous
nous cherchons la culture française sans
pesticides en cinq ans en accompagnant
les agriculteurs et je me fonde sur des
résultats puisque nous avons chez nous
une eurodéputée mireille d'ornano qui
était coordinatrice là au parlement
européen de la commission pesticides ou
qu'elle connaît le sujet parker n'a fait
des colloques et elle a fait voter un
amendement à 550 voix ça c'est une belle
victoire qui interdit l'épandage des
pesticides près des lieux sensibles
c'est à dire les écoles les ehpad et
donc il faut continuer dans cette voie
mais je le dit compter sur l'union
européenne pour faire cela là on est
pragmatique on prend quelques mesures
quand on peut quand on peut on prend
mais comptez sur l'union européenne pour
lutter contre les pesticides ou contre
la pollution générale c'est se fourvoyer
il faut évidemment quitter l'union
européenne et retrouver une capacité de
d'avoir une puissance publique au
service d'une agriculture durable et
d'accords commerciaux respectueux de
l'environnement alors pascal durand
votre position sur cette question ce
qu'une agriculture en cinq ans sans
pesticides plongée faisable ou témoin je
ne suis pas en capacité là maintenant de
dire il d'imposer ses trois ans et cinq
ans et deux ans est alors sans parler de
délais voilà on va va essayer de placer
au bon niveau parce que là on est en
train de confondre le niveau national et
le niveau or pas là on va passer au
niveau européen au niveau européen la
france a une position qui était très
clair c'était un de s'opposer aux 15 ans
qui était proposée par la commission
pour le renouvellement est effectivement
michel et patrick ont raison de rappeler
que le parlement européen lui a demandé
l'interdiction malheureusement nous ne
sommes pas qu'au législateur sur ce
sujet là et derrière et a
malheureusement
malheureusement l'allemand
i peut-être à cause du rachat de
monsanto par bayer peut-être à
abandonner la position française et a
fait basculer la majorité donc on est
sur un renouvellement de cinq ans donc
clairement il faut que dans la prochaine
mandature nous arrivions à faire en
sorte que les états et que donc la
france vous dites parlementaires
européens les parlementaires européens
ils se sont prononcés ils ont il faut
sortir ans dit maintenant il ne faut pas
c'était d'ailleurs il ya à peu près un
an donc maintenant reste quatre ans donc
il faut quand on arrive à faire en sorte
que le conseil européen donc les états
bouge la position de la france statut
est très claire elle veut l'interdiction
du glyphosate
je rappelle quand même qu effectivement
il ya des produits les néonicotinoïdes
qui tuent les abeilles les fameux tueur
d'abeilles mais également sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens xterra
l'europe est en pointe et elle est
insuffisante sur beaucoup de sujets
michel le sait mais elle est quand même
alors j'ai été à la pointe d'un combat
pour faire en sorte que ses produits
sont interdits sur un sujet qui dépend
des états membres et après il est clair
qu'il faudra donner les moyens de
financement aussi pour accompagner
on ne fera pas de transition sur ces
sujets là comme sur d'autres
en opposant les uns aux autres donc il
faut accompagner les agriculteurs il
faut accompagner
j'ai vu par exemple la sncf la sncf en
france dit on a des problèmes sur nos
rails on ne sait pas traiter sans
glyphosate donc l'information vienne
nous donner michel est sûrement très
intéressante mais ça veut dire que
peut-être elle va coûter plus cher
peut-être donc on va être obligés de
travailler là dessus mais c'est un enjeu
majeur
et oui l'europe est en capacité d'y
répondre et bien moins que les états
pris individuellement
quelques minutes avant la fin de cette
émission je vous propose d'abord
d'écouter le parti lutte ouvrière qui a
lui aussi une feuille de route pour
l'écologie nathalie arthaud tout de
suite ce grand capital avec sa politique
à courte vue où il faut faire des
profits le plus possible plus rapidement
possible il est en train de tuer la
planète à petit feu donc pour nous la
question de l'écologie
elle nécessite aussi d'imposer un
contrôle un contrôle sur ces grands
groupes industriels et financiers
c'est une question d'organisation de la
société et il faut avoir cette volonté
est bien mais contraindre de les
contraintes de les mettre sous
surveillance et de leur imposer
effectivement que les intérêts de
l'environnement soient pris en compte
on a essayé de respecter les temps parle
de chacun je vais vous demander pour
terminer en douceur cette émission une
mesure
car pour l'environnement si vous ne
deviez en citer qu'une seule michèle
rivasi pour l'environnement ce serait
quoi
à moi c'est très clair ça serait la
sortie des pesticides sur cinq ans mais
pesticides pas que le glyphosate envoyer
tous les insecticides et les herbicides
les fongicides etc
parce que c'est en train de nous tuer à
petit fait un petit feu quand vous voyez
l'épidémie de leucémie les épidémies de
cancer de façon globale les problèmes de
diabète d'obésité etc
il ya une grosse part qui est dû à ces
produits qu'on consomme qu'on respire et
qu'on boit donc pour moi c'est
l'interdiction d'aller au travail et
vous l'avez comprend quelques mots en
deux mots c'est changer de logiciel on
nous explique depuis trente ans que ce
logiciel peut fonctionner que ça va
s'améliorer que ça sera mieux demain
moi je crois que ce n'est pas possible
je crois qu'il faut changer le logiciel
est une mesure phare ça serait de
défiscaliser de détaxer de diminuer le
coût de tout ce qui est local favoriser
les circuits courts met des priorités
dans les marchés publics les cantines
local tout faire du local local le local
le local qui s'opposent à ce qui est
aujourd'hui l'union européenne
c'est-à-dire le libre échange au niveau
mondial pascal et patrick le hyaric
pardon au lieu que la banque centrale
européenne fabrique de la monnaie chaque
jour pour donner aux uniquement aux
banques privées
nous nous préférions que sai à un fonds
de développement social et
environnemental notamment pour mais pour
développer le transport en commun le le
train met les camions sur le train et
faire un grand plan de rénovation est
bonne et logements et pascal durand
alors justement là-dessus auprès de la
banque alors la banque européenne du
climat et pour financer les transitions
s'est absolument essentiel vous demandez
d'abord parce qu'il faut financer les
transitions et puis juste un point pour
rejoindre ce qu'a dit michel une
expertise européenne indépendante d
agence européenne d'évaluation des
produits ans on en a vraiment besoin et
bagnères monsanto la trouver merci
beaucoup à vous cas d'avoir participé à
cette émission les élections open c'est
le 26 mai prochain mais on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour parler
immigration avec orianne mancini et
quatre autres candidats merci à tous
[Musique]
on